this was the first visit of a Brazilian
head of state to Germany for more than
10 years president Lula D Silva arrived
at the chancellory to a reception that
was warm and businesslike bilateral
deals were signed on protecting the
environment and enhancing social justice
but D Silva was focused on hopes of a
wider deal between the EU and the South
American Block
mercosur as long as I'm able to believe
this agreement is possible I'm going to
fight to do it because if we don't agree
it after 23 years I think we're all
being unreasonable with the demands
we're
making Germany sees Brazil as its most
important South American Trading partner
one that should have a greater role in
world
affairs we need reformed International
institutions we are united in believing
that the UN Security Council should be
reformed and I think the changing World
demands that the voices of the global
South be heard and that those countries
have greater representation but they do
disagree on the war in Ukraine UK and in
Gaza Lula Silva says the UN should
intervene to protect civilians but Olaf
Schultz insists on Israel's right to
defend itself while trying to avoid
civilian casualties so in some ways this
was never entirely going to be a Meeting
of Minds but in reactivating their
governmental cooperation the two leaders
have chosen to emphasize the views they
share rather than the ones they don't
Dominic Kane Al jazer Berlin
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer